what's up tasty I'm David and like you i
fellow tasty producers and I've been
stuck at home it's just a safer place to
be right now with social distance that
doesn't mean we can't still cook
together right so I'm gonna ask all my
friends will recently become home chefs
to submit their best at home quarantine
proof recipes help us get through these
tough times and each episode you're
gonna decide which recipes the best
welcome to quarantine chef down
you guys my name is Kelly Paige I live
in Los Angeles California me my husband
energy kids are stuck inside our
two-bedroom house we're trying to do a
lot of cooking with our three-year-old
because he is a very active little guy
and he is bored as hell and today I'm
going to be making a wrench chicken pot
pie with cheddar drop biscuits hey
everybody I'm Andrew and I am here in my
home in Los Angeles and I'm gonna show
you how to make my all-time favorite
comfort food pasta carbonara so the
first thing I'm going to do is try my
veggies I'm saving any scraps I might
have and I'll freeze them and make some
sort of stock with them and accept my
new some carrots the thing I love about
Pat pies is it's the amazing way
it's just named veggies in and you can
customize it so things your kids will
eat whatever you find wine in your
fridge or freezer feel free to add it
you can't go wrong here so one trick for
a perfectly poached egg is white vinegar
I'm using white wine vinegar what the
vinegar is gonna do it's gonna help the
egg whites Lilla by let's go ahead and
drop in our egg you can see the whites
are kind of forming around the yolk and
that's just the egg doing its thing this
should take about 90 seconds to two
minutes all right this egg is poached
perfectly so I'm just going to transfer
to a paper towel-lined plate and then
we'll save it until we're ready to plate
it up I have not about three tablespoons
of butter over low heat just until
softened about five minutes
this little guy does he was ten D he
woke up early from his nap he's no help
mommy
no pretty onion no prints unions
are curious potatoes now he's gonna cook
these until they're soft until finish
cooking em in the oven you like that yes
next I'm going to air
and cauliflower again we're not cooking
this drew we're just gonna let it pop a
little bit and I'll finish cooking in
the oven once we put the biscuit on top
now I'm gonna add in my garlic and
nitrogen to use microphones to grade it
in 30 seconds minutes I'm gonna add the
flour to make our roux so cook this like
three to four minutes stirring
occasionally so it doesn't burn the
bottom of the pan and then after that
we'll add our milk then slowly add the
milk in scraping up all the brown bits
on the bottom of the pan and then let it
simmer until it's thickened this can
take anywhere from five to seven minutes
depending on how high your heat is but
just keep watching it to make sure it's
not burning on the bottom this is almost
there I'm gonna add that ranch seasoning
packet oh my god it smells so good it
smells like my childhood you know this
is getting this is exactly what we want
I'm gonna turn the heat on chicken and
there's ooh Keeney
so you might be wondering why I didn't
cook the zucchini with the rest of the
veggies and they'll get a chance to cook
when it goes in the oven this is looking
perfect it's thickened everything's well
combined I'm just gonna let it sit to
come to room temperature wait for
yelling to wake up and then we'll make
the biscuits what'd you say action and
what are we gonna make love you ready
you washed your hands are you guys no I
don't have enough flour to make biscuits
so we're using pancake mix say we have
pancake mix yeah that has all of our
leavening agents pinky yeah that's a
pinch no too much perfect now you're
gonna whisk it together with a spoon
and don't forget eggs what is that it's
cheese this is butter I'm gonna bully
okay can you draw a woman is very cool
butter oops
and why are we using cold butter cause
we like coke brothers so mommy's gonna
break up all these little butter pieces
until they're the size of peas so this
looks great to me what's your everyone
I'm gonna go wash my hands so I'm gonna
start chop the bacon and then we're
gonna cook it I'm gonna go over medium
heat and I'm gonna add in the bacon now
into a cold pan it looks the fat render
out a lot pepper I'd use the same bowl
and put the egg into it and then we'll
whisk it up right on the countertop way
you know there won't be any shells you
can cook the bacon so he's crispy really
don't need to do anything fancy with it
you're gonna cook it till it gets crispy
you're gonna take it out of the pan
using a slotted spoon and you're gonna
set aside on a paper towel lined plate I
got all this beautiful round bacon bits
in the pan and all this bacon fat I just
want to have a little bit more fat to
this butter butter we're gonna let that
melt down and then what we're gonna do
we're actually gonna create the sauce
using some boiling water and what I also
want to do is I want to add one of my
favorite things and something that's
very important to this dish is cheese so
I'm just gonna throw in a bunch of
Parmesan cheese into this kind of
boiling water mixture I'll let that all
melt and create this really creamy sauce
I'm gonna bring this up to a boil I'm
gonna let it simmer away until it's all
melted together and really silky and
beautiful can I'll get this boiling
season it a little bit with some salt
when I went into this social isolation
period I went to the grocery store and I
was able to find everything that kind of
me did but I was not able to get pasta
so what I had to do was I had to get a
little creative I went into my pantry
and I found an old friend from my early
20s
Robin is here from Symantec so we're
just gonna add a block of Robin what you
can do is you can grab a fork and kind
of work it around here this should take
maybe three minutes okay so you want to
turn off the heat once you've gotten to
this step the common mistake galapiat
make for making carbonara is that they
throw the eggs in when pastas too hot
we're going to saw in the heat and then
you have scrambled eggs in your dish you
really want it to create a cohesive
sauce I have my one kind of later
scrambled egg I'm gonna toss it in here
we're just gonna really quickly throw it
all together and you can see it kind of
all coming together as one a little bit
more of the boiling water if you we've
got this really nice creamy eggy pasta I
want to throw in our bacon so we added
the milk and stir it in sick like this
now we're just gonna drop it on top of
our casserole and make it so just take a
big dollop and scoop it on top hey can I
cook this for 20 minutes in a 400-degree
oven the oven perfect visits are cooked
through they're golden brown filling is
bubbling away all right Teddy Danny
the potpie is out of the oven I've let
it cool a little bit and I'm gonna serve
it up to Dylan and see what he thinks
so that is it that's how you make this
ranch chicken pot pie with cheddar drop
biscuits
I think his favorite part is the biscuit
okay it is so fluffy it is so tender and
who would have known it's made from
pancakes you see it steaming it looks
creamy delicious bacony eggy you can eat
this for breakfast lunch or dinner no
matter what I'm going to top it with
more cheese another major component this
is black pepper
and now for the piece de resistance our
poached egg on top
Oh egg yolk
[Music]
there's something about this it's giving
me nostalgia it's giving me comfort all
at the same time it's kind of you know
taking my mind off of everything that's
going on right now and I am very excited
for you guys to make this I think you're
really gonna enjoy it
Wow Andrew that looks amazing you're
definitely gonna give Kelly a run for
her money so if you could only choose
one recipe out of those two to make
while you're stuck at home on quarantine
which one would it be
would you go with Andrews ramen noodle
carbonara or would it be Kelly's chicken
pot pie with biscuits let us know in the
comments below and if you happen to be
watching this on the day it comes out
head over to taste these instagrams
story and vote there once you ought to
stay safe and remain healthy remember
we're gonna get through this together
I'm David and I'll see you next time oh
yes
[Music]
you